la estructura del metro se derrumba una
caída de 20 metros de altura que provocó
la muerte de 26 personas y dejó 80
heridos el accidente conmocionó a la
ciudad de mexico y provocó el caos en el
transporte para millones de mexicanos de
la periferia el autobús es ahora la
única forma de llegar al centro de la
capital
aquí es donde trabaja el yo de galicia y
todos los días comienza su jornada a las
6 de la mañana se duplicaba el inicio
cuando empezó lo del accidente hoy
también una hora y media de dos horas
estos sobres y médicos dispensados en
promedio gastaba diez quince pesos
diarios ahora a veces de repente tengo
que gastar hasta cuarenta después de
recorrer un tercio del trayecto el
autobús se detiene por una avería
mecánica hay que volver a tomar otro hay
mucha gente hay que buscar otra opción y
es tiempo y dice ya es muy tarde en
estas colonias periféricas de tláhuac e
iztapalapa se han construido miles de
viviendas en las últimas décadas la
población ha crecido muy rápido la
infraestructura no ha seguido el ritmo
la ciudad de méxico está desbordada por
sus 23 millones de habitantes
y ven como la situación empeora con cada
nueva crisis por estos sismos del 85 del
2017 y hoy de la pandemia
ha llegado y ha metido a gente en
lugares donde no tienen la calidad de
vida ni los servicios necesarios no
había suficientemente hambre entonces
eso conjunta con la pandemia originó que
eso fuera una de las alcaldías más
contagiadas en la ciudad de mexico la
megalópolis también sufre los caprichos
de la naturaleza aquí el terremoto de
2017 dejó una cicatriz gigante
la grieta atraviesa desde la colonia de
más escuelas y esta área parte del
parque que no se ha hecho nada al
respecto de eso indican que esas grietas
van a estar ahí todo el tiempo que
tenemos que aprender a vivir con ellas
vivir al margen del desarrollo
los habitantes de tlahuac no tenían otra
opción en los últimos 20 años el precio
medio de los inmuebles se ha
quintuplicado aproximadamente un millón
250 mil personas de bajos ingresos han
sido excluidas socialmente hacia las
afueras de la capital las autoridades
apenas están empezando a abordar el
problema hay un programa para hacer más
accesibles algunas viviendas del centro
como funciona en muchos países del mundo
no en francia en alemania en italia en
eeuu donde gran parte la un tercio de la
vivienda que se construye para la venta
tiene que ser ofrecida a las familias de
menores ingresos pero la gentrificación
ya ha pasado factura jorge vaca nació en
el barrio de santa maría la ribera cerca
del centro la zona todavía tenía una
cara popular hace unos años
había un zapatero muy antiguo que tenía
40 50 años trabajando vendieron la
propiedad y ahora pues pretenden
construir departamentos
aquí la tierra para el habitante antiguo
como yo es cara pero para un
inmobiliario es baratas en mi casa no sé
cuánto pueda valer 10 millones de pesos
para mí es mucho dinero para un
inmobiliario 10 millones de pesos es
poco porque construyen 10 departamentos
cada uno de 3 millones de pesos
y la pandemia fue casi el golpe de
gracia para las últimas pequeñas
empresas de negocio tienen más de 80
años pero como que va
ahorita este tiempo de pandemia también
va cómo poco a poco en los últimos 20
años el precio medio de los inmuebles se
ha cuadruplicado el costo de vida ha
seguido la misma tendencia los productos
del mercado los productos de consumo
cotidiano es digamos las frutas
legumbres etcétera si ha habido un
incremento mayor no así que como acto de
resistencia
jorge creó a santamarina juar y acá una
santa bastante especial esta iniciativa
artística y humorística ha dado lugar a
una nueva devoción popular en la reja
vamos para el fondo de los malos
funcionarios en contra de la que pues
desde luego contra la simplificación
durante años jorge ha tratado de alertar
a los residentes sobre los efectos
perversos de la gentrificación es decir
una casa que durante años detuvo un
vidrio roto al otro día la compró
alguien una inmobiliaria y le cambió el
vidrio y le pintó la fachada y le puso
un foco nuevo y la gente dijo bravo qué
bueno está mejorando la colonia sí pero
no para ti tú vas a ser desplazado
la ciudad de mexico es víctima de su
propio gigantismo el accidente del metro
ha puesto de manifiesto una brecha
social que se ha ido ampliando durante
décadas